today a District of Columbia federal
court will hear the case of a woman who
fled the u.s. to join Isis and now
insists she has the right to come back
to America Poe DeMuth auna was born in
New Jersey in wand and says she wants to
return home with her infant son the
Trump administration does not consider
her a US citizen Charlie d'Agata spoke
with the 24 year old in northern Syria
where she is pleading for a second
chance
Oh DeMuth Anna joined Isis by choice
getting back home is now completely out
of her hands what would you say to the
Americans who say oh dear you're not
welcome in America anymore I was only 19
when I made my decision and you know
people want their young they make very
big stupid mistakes they don't come much
bigger or more stupid than joining a
terrorist group and done destroying
America
she's also accused of personally
inciting attacks against Americans the
President of the United States himself
said that you're not welcome back to
America what would you say to him we
told him to study the legal system I
have papers I have citizenship at the
same time we thana says she understands
the anger and hatred she's caused in the
United States I ruined my life I ruined
my son's future but I wouldn't have had
a son if I didn't come that's the only
regret I don't know I want I wouldn't
have see him girl phone array same to me
are you willing to go to jail if that's
what it takes to go back to America yes
and what's to become of Adam the son of
a dead Isis fighter they didn't even
have a birth certificate for CBS this
morning Charlie d'Agata nothing in
northern Syria a lot of mixed news on
this story in this country